des masques censés nous protéger qui se
retrouve au coeur d'une polémique dont
le gouvernement se serait bien passé en
cause le graphène ce nanomatériau
composant principal de ces ffp2 pourtant
présenté comme révolutionnaire par les
industriels et le centre national de la
recherche scientifique ultra-résistant
ultra-léger imperméable on lui a même
trouvé des propriétés antivirales en
avril 2020 le gouvernement commande à la
chine plus de 60 millions de ces masques
ffp2 des masques est livré avec une
notice dont les détails ont apparemment
échappé aux autorités de santé près de
17 millions de ces masques distribués
aux soignants sont rappelés parce que
jugée potentiellement dangereux
le 25 mai dernier et santé publique
france publie une note destinée aux
personnels de santé
une note se voulait discrète et qui
passe alors inaperçu urgent informations
de sécurité
votre structure est susceptible d'avoir
été destinataires de masques labellisés
bio masse graphène dans la tente de
l'évaluation de l'éventuel risque est
lié à la présence de graphène dans ces
masques et par précaution il vous est
demandé de ne plus les utiliser
une information rapidement appuyées par
l' agence régionale de santé
ile-de-france dans un document daté du
même jour
à ce stade il a été identifié 70 5
millions de masques ffp2 doté d'un
marquage ce et eux pouvant
potentiellement contenir du graphène
dont 16,9 millions ont d'ores et déjà
été distribuées en 2020
ces masques ont principalement été
distribués aux établissements de santé
et établissements médico-sociaux leur a
fallu une lettre d' alerte adressée à la
commission européenne par quatre ong
dont al-qaïda autres armes ou encore la
décision de certains pays comme le
canada de retirer lançant le dff p2 en
circulation sur leur territoire pour que
les pouvoirs publics prennent enfin les
choses au sérieux ces masques en
polypropylène sont potentiellement
toxiques les laisser sur le marché
pourrait dangereusement ébranlé la
confiance du public dans le port de
masques
deux mois après ces alertes au canada le
gouvernement français prend enfin des
mesures similaires pour appeler
l'ensemble de ces masques alors comment
sont ils arrivés sur le nez des
soignants des hôpitaux de l'hexagone
interrogé par nos confrères de mediapart
santé publique
on joue la carte du mea culpa en
avançant que c'est comme en date d'avril
2020 avec un avis favorable de l'agencé
nationale de la sécurité du médicament
mais que la mention bio masse graphène
semble avoir échappé
pourtant toute notion de biocides
devrait être rédhibitoire comme l'a
expliqué santé publique france
l'utilisation des biocides était un
critère d'exclusion dans le cahier des
charges des autorités sanitaires
ces masques n'aurait donc jamais dû être
distribués aux soignants santé publique
france explique que cette commande avait
été passée en avril 2020 avec un avis
est favorable de la haine s m
pourtant dans le rapport de test ainsi
que dans la notice du fabricant la
mention de biomasse graphène
apparaissait bien reconnaît spf
aujourd'hui il est plus de 43 millions
de masques ffp2 stockées par l'état
voient leur distribution gelé alors
s'agit-il d'une réalité devenue
embarrassante ou bien d'une erreur
d'appréciation
près d'un an et demi après le début de
la crise la france semble vouloir se
voiler la face sur certains aspects de
sa gestion de l'épidémie